[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ce quartier une belle journée pour
notre voisin
qu'est-ce que tu es à moi
au revoir
mais ils faisaient appel
comment tu [
Musique] j'ai
toujours voulu avoir
J'ai toujours voulu
[Musique]
alors
profitons au maximum de cette belle
journée que nous sommes ici aux Oscars, alors autant
rester, serais-tu à moi, comment peux-tu
être mon voisin
mon voisin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir nous célébrons l'art de
raconter des histoires Oh les
marginaux les parias les incompris
ces voix le long du prix soient fortes soyez
vues nous nous laissons entendre ce soir
la plus grande soirée de votre vie tous
habillés la plus grande guitare
[Musique]
oups
les petites femmes le
site des Dolomites est l'heure de faire du shopping
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
comment  allez, c'est comme ça
tout le monde vient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]